as we follow the river
deeper the environment becomes more
challenging this terrain gave the Cho
natural protection from their
enemies
okay
[Music]
right
can we go
around let's let's
see I have a rope I have a
rope I'll go up first and I'll tie off
the rope and then I'll pull you
up
wait got
you
[Music]
wow s
oh
man now I just feel like I'm in some
otherworldly
magic where are
[Laughter]
we
oh a will
seea as we reach 9,000 ft there are
signs of life and death all around
us it's a deceiving drop okay buddy
because it's just a c cliff and then you
got trees but the cliff keeps going so
sure you don't
[Music]
fall it's up there mhm mhm okay well
okay
there's definitely a sense of
anticipation I'm exploring the most
intimate parts of someone's
story
[Music]
here that's hair that's hair
I'm just a few feet from human
hair this is the remains of the judge
AA this is a
[Music]
[Applause]
person
[Music]
oh
I've never seen anything like
this I don't know why I just feel like I
have to whisper you know it feels like
something so
[Applause]
sacred
[Music]
unbelievable